tenemos aquí un rectángulo y digamos que
sabemos que su área es 42 por equis
porque a la 3
esto de aquí es el área
área de este rectángulo y digamos que
también sabemos que el alto de este
rectángulo es 14 por x por jeff y como
te puedes imaginar lo que queremos hacer
en este vídeo es encontrar el ancho de
este rectángulo y bueno pues va a estar
escrito en términos algebraicos así es
que pone pausa el vídeo y averigua cuál
es el ancho de este rectángulo si el
alto es 14 x y el área es 42 x porque al
cubo bueno a ver cómo encontramos el
área de un rectángulo pues tomamos el
ancho que en este ejercicio le vamos a
llamar l para que sea más fácil tomamos
el ancho y lo multiplicamos por el alto
del rectángulo osea que queremos
multiplicar a él por 14 x
esto lo que nos da es el área pero el
área es 42 por x porque al cubo y a
partir de esto como encontramos la l
pues dividimos de los dos lados por 14 x
que hay entonces eso es lo que vamos a
hacer ahorita entonces vamos a dividir
el lado izquierdo y el lado derecho
entre 14 x y ok entre 14 x y ahora del
lado izquierdo estamos multiplicando y
dividiendo por 14 x y eso pues es
exactamente igual a estar multiplicando
y dividiendo por 1 aunque yo entonces
esto se cancela y nos queda simplemente
la l queda el ancho del rectángulo que
es justo el punto de estar dividiendo
aquí entre 14 x entonces tenemos que l
es igual a esto del lado derecho y
podemos primero fijarnos en los
coeficientes tenemos 42 entre 14
y eso es 3 y después por acá tenemos x
entre x eso es simplemente un 1 y
finalmente tenemos ya al cubo / jr ig al
cubo entre y es simplemente cuadrada y
listo
ya terminamos nuestro ancho estrés
porque al cuadrado el ancho de este
rectángulo estrés porque al cuadrado